It's strong together.
Before you see the two of us, we have some lovely ladies to open the show for us.
Who is gonna go first, men?
Who's gonna go first?
It is a show that is out of this world!
And that is to agree for Miss Pia!
Welcome, welcome, one and all!
Pia Pia UFO, we'll be officiating these ceremonies.
So please find a nice seat up here in the front.
You wouldn't want to miss it.
Panda hat guy gets it?
Hey Panda hat guy, you wanna be the ring boy?
Yes, well together, we'll be joining these two brides in the holy vows of matrimony.
Matrimony, wait.
Excuse me, I thought that they were gonna be on the stage.
I mean, it's their wedding, I just...
What?
The final act?
Captain!
This is their wedding invite!
There seems to have been a small programming...
Wait, cut the music, cut the music.
Let's try this again.
Welcome, welcome, one and all, to the event of the season, Phantom Thieves!
Alright, now just give me a second to clean all this up.
Oh gosh, oh jeez, where's my manager?
Oh god, I really screwed this one up, huh?
This is why you can't blindly trust people on the internet.
Look, so what if I got a little de lulu about my Oshis maybe marrying each other?
You can't say it never happened to you!
What are you gonna do about it anyway, huh?
Sue me?
Oh wait, really?
Can I do my set first?
Oh, alright, well then let's get this show on the road!
Give me one second here.
Alright, hit it!
I want to believe in love It
is my bo- It is my bo- I
want to believe in love It is my bo- I want to believe in love I don't know if you can hear it, but I'm singing this song.
Do you wanna play?
Real game.
A melody that seems to cross the line.
I can't admit it, I can't go back, I want to forget it.
I'll stick it in my dream.
I won't be free.
I can see a new era.
To the other side of the world.
Let's go, new world.
I believe in this future.
If I can endure it step by step.
I don't have a dream.
Believe in me.
Let's make reality colorful.
Music.
It's starting now.
Rising.
Let's close our eyes and run away together.
I'll show you something better than now.
If you sing this song.
Do you wanna play?
Real game.
A melody that seems to cross the line.
I can't admit it, I can't go back, I want to forget it.
I'll stick it in my dream.
I won't be free.
I can see a new era.
To the other side of the world.
Let's go, new world.
I believe in this future.
If I can endure it step by step.
I can't admit it, I can't go back, I want to forget it.
I'll stick it in my dream.
To the other side of the world.
I believe in this future.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
And I wonder if some people can help me with this one.
Please don't ask me.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
Very, very cool.
Thank you very much for having me today.
And if that one didn't get you dancing, this next one definitely will.
You know, I've been practicing.
I've been buzzing my lips all morning for this.
But let's just jump right into it.
We're gonna sing...
Bling!
I need to change my hat.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
Very, very cool.
And if that one didn't get you dancing, this next one definitely will.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
Thank you very much for having me today.
And if that one didn't get you dancing, this next one definitely will.
I've been buzzing my lips all morning for this.
But let's just jump right into it.
We're gonna sing...
Bling!
Very, very cool.
Thank you very much for having me today.
To the next, to the next.
Now sing it.
Well, that was a lot of Nihongo.
For the Nihongo, Jozu, Janai folks, why don't we put something on for them in English, I was thinking.
And since we're in a chapel, I mean, that's what a tabernacle is, right?
It's a chapel.
I was thinking, you know, chapel, chapel, tabernacle, why don't we sing some chapel row?
Why don't we sing some chapel row?
What do you miss, guys, huh?
Alright, sing along with me and dance it if you know it.
Alright.
Hat off.
Wait, no, you know what?
Hat on, yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Five, six, five, six, seven, eight.
I could be the one or your new addiction It's all in my head but I want no fiction I don't want the world but I'll take this city Who can blame a girl, call me hot, not pretty Baby, do you like this beat?
I made it so you dance with me It's like a hundred ninety-nine degrees When you're doing it with me, doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O, snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now, body roll, dance it out, you're hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O, snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now,
body roll, H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go I woke up alone staring at my ceiling I try not to care but it hurts my feelings You don't have to stare, come here, get with it No one touch me there in a damn hot minute Baby,
don't you like this beat?
I made it so you sleep with me It's like a hundred ninety-nine degrees When you're doing it with me, doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O, snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now, body roll, dance it out, you're hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O, snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now,
body roll, H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go What's it take to get your number?
What's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time to stop, I don't know how to go What's it take to get your number?
Hurry up, it's getting cold Hurry up, it's time to suffer Hurry up, I'm hot to go
Hot to go
You gonna OSHI me?
Okay, that's enough You can cheer three You
know, unfortunately, it is time for my last song I know, I know But this song means a lot to me And it means a lot to a lot of people And so I hope I can do it justice Let me know how I did using the hashtag BadDumpDanceRevenge
But it is time for...
God knows
Give me all you got See, it's time for my last Everybody, you're on the break tonight
I can't do anything Even if we share the pain
You won't forgive me Every time I live with a grudge I turn my back and leave I don't know the end I'll follow you No matter how hard the world is I'm sure you'll shine There's a future beyond
弱さゆえに魂壊されぬように My way 重なるよ今 二人に God bless
熱くなる想いは 現実 溶かして彷徨う I want to see you, but I don't have a reason.
You are overflowing, loving you.
At least, let's chase after a beautiful dream.
For your lonely eyes.
Stop it, it's not like you to lie.
Look into my eyes and let's talk about the future.
I am prepared.
Even in the dark future, I will become stronger.
Maybe I can change my fate.
My wish, I want to make it come true.
Everything is God knows.
You say it, I say it.
The others have disappeared.
While drawing the beauty of a faint dream.
I will heal the wounds.
So, I will follow you.
No matter how painful the world is, even in the darkness.
Surely, you will shine.
So that my soul won't be destroyed by the weakness of the future.
My way overlaps now.
To the two of us, God bless.
Yeah, you are the beauty.
But anyways, give it up, one last round.
Who's the next opener?
Next up, be transported to a wonderful fairy tale.
Of honeybees and cuteness.
Give it up for Phoebe.
Hello.
As we say at my Phoebe High community.
And you can say now too, ohaji.
Ohaji.
How are you all doing tonight?
You will be buzzing.
With excitement.
Sorry, sorry.
With excitement to be here at Phantom Thieves Revenge.
Even though it's virtual, today is my first time performing in Georgia.
And I'm honestly pretty nervous.
Thank you for the warm welcome.
And thank you so much to Mint Toki and Ushi Spark for having me as well.
I was like, I was messaging backstage.
And I was like, oh, I'm kind of sweating here, I'm kind of nervous.
And then they're like, don't worry, everyone's so hyped up.
And then they sent me a picture of how big the crowd was.
And I was like, oh yeah, that's definitely going to help me feel better about this.
But seriously, seriously, I'm so honored to be here.
Thank you.
I'm Phoebe, your 2.5D fairytale idol, singer, songwriter, and voice actor.
I love to write my own songs and perform them on both the virtual stage as a VTuber and the real-life stage as a real-life idol.
I've been working my hardest for the past several years to bridge the virtual and real-life worlds.
And touch as many hearts as I can all over the world with my voice, including your song.
Let's write our fairytale together, shall we, you guys?
Well, I'm an idol and it's the holiday season.
And so for this first song, I think a lot of you guys will kind of know what to expect.
Maybe, hopefully.
I want to make a holiday miracle of sorts happen here.
So if you happen to have any spare ULs lying around, I know I'm making you use your ULs so early on in the concert, I'm sorry.
Not sorry, but you'll know what to do when the time comes.
So please enjoy this first song.
You know it?
Here we go.
Snow Halation.
不思議だね 今の気持ち 不思議だね 今の気持ち 空から降ってきたみたい 空から降ってきたみたい
特別な季節の色が トキメキを見せる
初めて出会った時から 予感に騒ぐ 心のメロディー I can't stop it.
I can't stop it.
Why?
I can't let it go.
Let's get started.
Until our feelings overlap.
I can't wait.
It's frustrating, but it's going well.
In the crisis, we can't hesitate.
We'll take the courage to jump in.
It's almost time.
Quietly, fate.
The future from now on.
I want to run to you right away and hug you.
Wherever you are, wherever you are.
Fly high.
Before I knew it, I was alone.
This emotion has grown too big.
It's hard to see only dreams.
I want to be with you, my lover.
I don't want to be confused by sad dreams.
Let's live like this.
I took a deep breath.
Amazing.
Thank you so much.
Are we going to be able to make that holiday miracle happen?
Let's give it a shot, shall we?
From pink to what color?
Red.
Here we go.
Thank you so much, everybody.
And I'll give it up for my backup dancers to the B4.
Thank you, guys.
Oh my gosh, that was incredible.
Thank you.
I almost cried there.
So thank you so much.
You seriously made a Christmas miracle happen.
Or Hanukkah, or Kwanzaa, or whatever you celebrate.
Speaking of miracles, Could I ask you all for a favor?
Can we do my idol call and response really quick?
If we pull this off, I think this might be the biggest crowd I've ever done my call and response with.
So it's real easy.
I'm going to ask you three questions.
And we're going to cheat on this test.
I'm going to give you the answers to them.
They're all just parts of my name.
The answers are going to be in this order.
C, B, and CB.
Easy, right?
So, shall we give it a try?
Here we go.
This is the place to...
Who's the bee causing all the buzz?
Me!
We've
got more songs to go.
It really means more to me than you know, though.
Thank you so much.
Hopefully, I'll be able to come to that with you all again in person one day.
There are some things in Atlanta that I definitely want to see one day.
I heard that you guys have the one and only Waffle House Museum.
Is that true?
Maybe the first time we'll be in Atlanta with you guys.
Penelope, to help.
Hi, Penelope.
Hello.
She's real good at guitar.
Alright.
Here you go.
Here we go.
You guys know this.
Probably.
Here we go.
You know it now, right?
Come on!
The boots with the fur Shorty got the whole damn club Looking straight at her Baggy sweatpants The Reeboks with the straps Shorty turn around and give that big booty up She hit the floor and it's digging over She hit the floor and it's digging over She hit the floor and it's stinging over.
Shorty got a low.
She hit the floor and it's stinging over.
Your turn!
Apple bottom wet!
Them boots with the wet!
Shorty got the whole damn clump.
Looking straight at her.
Baggy sweatpants.
Three bucks with the straps.
Shorty turn around and give that big booty a slap.
She hit the floor and it's stinging over.
Come on!
Shorty got a low.
She hit the floor and it's stinging over.
One more time!
Apple bottom wet!
Boots with the wet!
Shorty got the whole damn clump.
Looking straight at her.
Yeah!
Shorty
got it just as you've known it from your childhood always, right?
Luckily, well, or unfortunately, I have just one more song for you.
I promise that we'll meet each other again.
For sure, okay?
Yes, we will!
Pinky promise, we will meet again.
So this is just to see you later, you know?
This next one, unlike the other covers that I've done, is an original song.
It is my newest original single, Your Harmony.
And it's really, really dear to my heart because I got a lot of precious VTubers, Kaigai Idol, and otake friends to sing along on it.
And a lot of the staff that worked on it as well were also really important friends that had come along with me on my journey for the past four years, four and a half years of VTubing and like five, six years of being an idol.
So, if you know it, and you know that some of you guys in the crowd do know it, please don't let's sing along to and, you know, help the others along too that might be hearing this song for the first time.
It's a song about chasing the same dreams alongside your friends and your peers, and maybe diverging along the way onto separate paths.
And despite that, you just keep cheering each other on and watching on in awe as you both accomplish amazing things.
And honestly, I'm a little sappy, but that's how I felt about Mint actually from when we both started out as VTuber sisters back in 2020 all the way up until now.
And she really really inspires me to this day.
So, please, please, listen to my song, Your Heart Will Go
On.
Your heart will go on
Where did you go?
You disappeared like stars on my horizon You took off I still lie awake I gotta find it if you guys reach out and hold on I will be here for you It's weird to chase, but you keep singing for me, see?
And if you find I'm far behind, I will make my voice and set you free Gather the sweetness I need But if you need me, I can be your harmony
Another dream that felt so real Another call, a fleeting twinkle in the twilight It's hard to stop the way I feel, clinging on too tight Where do I need to go?
I see a light that's only faintly gleaming You woke up I'm still dreaming I'm as bored as life so far, despite the calm of gravity Finding the love, the joy of life, I wanna sing it for you, see?
It's really not that we forgot, it's just the way it's meant to be Full of the past, but flying at last We're not in unison, but still in harmony If you know it, sing it with me!
I got a slightly dusty side, but I'll be climbing on the bridge If my life's made up to change, don't keep on singing for me, please And if you find I'm falling apart, baby, won't you set me free?
Another dream that felt so real, another call, a fleeting twinkle in the twilight I
hope you guys enjoyed Phantom Thief's Revenge.
Thank you!
Please,
please enjoy the rest of the night and we will meet each other again, promise.
Good night and bye bye!
I guess it's time for a final opening act.
Woah, getting closer and closer.
Who was up last, Doggie?
Well, someone very electrifying.
Woah!
I mean, it's only one person.
I mean, it's your first year, so you're the most popular.
Anyway, give it up for Juno Nagi!
Okay, Juno, it's fine.
Like, no one's gonna... we're not even live right now, right?
Like, no one's gonna see me, right?
Yeah, that'd be crazy if...
Oh.
I was definitely not throwing up, like, earlier or anything, no, but holy shit, did you guys hear the first two girls?
They sounded amazing!
They sounded so hot!
I love them so much, they're so, so talented and I should not be screaming because I'm actually a little sick right now.
But that's besides the point, right?
Haha, I'm still here and I'm here to give you a show.
Um, I will say, it's a little bit calmer because, you know, there has to be, like, the calm before the snow, the snow, the storm, because I don't know what Mint and Doki are up to.
They could be kissing right now, we would never know.
I will
show the course of Doki and Mint's love.
So, why don't we start with a breakup song?
I hate to give satisfaction, asking how you're doing now.
A house, a castle built on people you pretend to care about, just what you wanted.
Look at you, cool guy, you got it.
I see the parties and I'm diving, sometimes when I close my eyes, six months of torture you sold.
A self-forbidden paradise, I love you truly.
Gotta laugh at the stupidity.
Cause I've made some real big mistakes, but you make the worst ones look fine.
I should've known it was strange, you only come out at night.
I used to think I was smart, but you made me look so naive.
The way you sold me for gold, you suck your teeth into me.
Sucker, big fucker, bleeding me dry like a goddamn vampire.
I never talked to you, told me you were bad, bad news, you called them crazy.
Gotta hate the way I called them crazy too, you're so convincing.
How do I lie with all the foolish?
What a mess where I can paralyze you, fuck up little girl.
You can't figure out just how you do it, and I know they never will.
She deserves your age, no better.
I've made some real big mistakes,
but you didn't know it was strange.
You only
come out at night.
You suck your teeth into me.
Sucker, big fucker, bleeding me dry like a goddamn vampire.
You said it was too long, I wouldn't let me hide.
You can't love anyone, cause that would mean you had a heart.
I try to help you out, I know that I can't.
Cause cause you think the kind of thing you'll never understand.
I...
I've made some real big mistakes, but you didn't know it was strange.
You only come out at night.
You suck your teeth into me.
Sucker, big fucker, bleeding
me dry like a goddamn vampire.
That was crazy, wow, I really hit the notes, huh?
Yeah.
Forgot to mention this first, I saw someone recording the concert with 3DS.
Do you know how much 3DSs cost?
Well, you know what you do with 3DSs?
You play them with the homies.
You play Mario Kart with the homies, you make enemies.
But like, don't you have to kiss afterwards?
You gotta make up with your homies, right?
You got four kinds of homies, and this sucks.
So, I'm gonna tell you right now, if you know the lyrics to this next song, that it holds...
I hold it very close to my heart, actually.
So if you would sing along with me, I really appreciate that.
Let's go!
It was just two brothers, fucking on a guy, rubbing on his ass, picking up each other.
See it in your eyes, I'm gonna make you cry, underneath the cover.
I
don't...
Bitch, I...
Don't want my lies, running through my rubber.
Can you let me die, or I'm gonna blast, I got semen powers.
Fuck you in the shower.
Are you gonna hug a homie tonight?
Are you gonna tell them that you love them?
Look, you guys have to tell each other that you love each other.
You have to...
I'm just like, on your spare time, not in front of me.
Well, do you guys like that one?
I hope you did.
But yeah, so that was like, you know, the first song was about a breakup, the second song is about making up.
What could the third song be about?
No, you're wrong.
It's about being in a happy, healthy relationship, obviously.
I... the next one is... I wrote the English lyrics for it.
It's just a cover, but...
I hope you guys like it.
It's pretty smooth, slow, and I hope you dance along with me.
Let's go!
You and me, shimmering, I'm just feeling the break inside You and I, shimmering, all my fears I try to hide You and I, let's carry on, never wake from drunken wine Is it a monster, baby?
Shady light, mellow beat, voices that just never stop Days are worn red, center fading, gone by Cherry wine, pillow kiss, hear the voice inside me now I just want to bite a chip of you, so much rain La-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
Took all my hand in magic ways Lost my meaning, knowing everything is wrong In my youth, I ran away from the cause The kick from the sound, the voice so loud Trying to help me Check your white, yellow page What's this now?
We'll never know In the end, the sky fades Yet you're smiling Telling me you'll never stray Check your white, yellow kiss Hear the voice inside me now When it melts
White, yellow page What's this now?
Just never stop There's a word written A fading gone by Telling me you'll never stray Check your white, yellow kiss Hear the voice inside me now I just want To find a shade for you Too much rain Late at night Oh, so bright Illuminate Too much rain Late at night Oh,
so bright Turn away Too much rain I
think that was a pretty good song.
You know, after the whole guys fucking each other it was pretty calm, right?
Well, I'm glad you guys enjoyed the list so far.
You see, the last song I can't really say it's about a healthy relationship because I think someone dies at the end of the song so I don't think that's really good.
I don't think anyone should just stop living, so...
Well...
Oh my god, this is...
Oh my god, wait, hold on, I need a...
Oh, it's almost over.
You got this, you got this.
It's fine.
It's almost done.
It might be the end of this thing.
I screamed afterwards.
Well, it's coming to an end so are you ready for my original song, Pull the Trigger?
Goodbye.
So I'm a faker, a traitor A pathetic love chaser A cheap simitator An overdramatic instigator Summer blaze fades in my veins All of them gone without a trace I got a hunch you'd feel safer When cowering in envy with her And I can't hide And I already won Cause you're comfortable in your own misery You're temperable dirt and toxicity And tonight I'm letting go of the hold you have on me Now pull the trigger if you dare I'll laugh it away,
I'll laugh it away But take the vengeance in the air I'll defy what you say, I'll prove that I care Take one look at me, I'll be my mentor Marie Baby I know I'm meant to be You'll love me eternally
I'm here to fight for self-righteousness And spitefulness When you're out broken, tied on mess I'll convalesce your life in this shadow By my ardor and success I've broken all the ways up to the highest I'm the salt of the fall I can be the lowest, the lowest of the low Yeah,
you're shocked that I left you out all alone And I've got money and time And I already won Cause you follow the words of a hypocrite Like a sheep in a herd, and I'm sick of it And the highlight of my night Is watching the road I've so unfit Pull the trigger,
shoot me dead I can't get away, can't get away Contrive an ending in your head Faulty in your day, leave you in a daze There, as I succeed You know you're nothing without me Maybe you're just blind and you're happy Tell me one more time, cause this shit's a gig
Walking the hallway with you, baby The joys, the laughs, the memories Nothing I could do Nothing left to prove Everyone's eyes watching you Pull the trigger if you dare I'll love the way, I'll love the way That takes up everything in the air Take one look at me A real moment,
don't worry Baby, I know who I'm meant to be You'll remember me eternally The final slide tonight As it's for the third time in your life You're all I ever should I hope for you to be right So take one more look at me And let's fight all the time This isn't who you were meant to be We're just a little bit of a jealousy We only know what's on we Pull the trigger once again
Oh my god, thank you so much for having me here It was such a wonderful experience You guys are just amazing I
also have to say, before I go The cameraman was zooming in to the guy with the 3DS I can't, that made me fucking laugh I'm so sorry Thank
you so much Thank you so much
Because it's time for the main event, guys Yeah, we're gonna start Concert's cancelled, I'm playing Marvel Rivals Wait, what?
No, she's not serious, you guys She's not serious What's happening?
Wait
Alright, so, as you can see, I'm playing Stop it!
Luckily, there's a PC here So, here I am, playing Luna Snow And like, right now, so you see I'm trying to heal my team right now Who's that?
Well, they're Marvel heroes I don't know anything about Marvel It's okay, I don't either, it's a fun game Is that BBQ running around?
It's basically Overwatch 2
And the crowd goes wild Oh my god Look at those heels Oh, I'm dancing This is what the dance lessons were for, guys Right here, I'm gonna dance now What do we actually have to do?
I'm literally dancing Look, see?
Oh my god Heroes never die Sorry, wrong game Oh my god, it's the Hulk!
Where's Spider-Man?
There's no Spider-Man here No way Okay, watch this Look, she's challenging And then, look at her aim Oh, look at that Oh, get shot!
Oh man, zero deaths, by the way Zero deaths Let's finish the game back Don't worry, it's almost over You see that?
I'm almost at the point right here Alright, look at those heels Those insane heels Oh my god What a GG I'm the better gamer I don't know how I lost It's a good game Game of the year I am master I am master I am master I am master Bye-bye, take care I am zero deaths right here Look at those insane heels That's right That's right FPS YouTuber of the year
One more game One more game One more game
I'm going to be singing along.
All my wishies know that I love you.
If I'm your baby shout it out.
I really love
you.
No need to be shy, just say I love you.
And I'll embrace you even more.
Love's just a knock and win.
I'm gonna find you in my hands.
Trust me.
That means it's a tie.
Well, yes, that's fine.
Everything's gonna be okay, don't worry, dear.
And everybody's gonna choose the very best.
That's right.
Each time.
You'll find.
It's gonna be better, so just say bye.
And hit like.
Hit like.
Blowing up is everything you've got.
All right.
Remember, all you need to know is just be shy.
That's right.
I'm so sweet.
Embracing everything.
You'll win me over.
You can love me more.
From here to
vacation.
Well, the stamina of a streamer has the power.
The whole nation.
With slower rhythms.
I know.
It's an extraordinary panel.
And shows up at the stars loud.
Donkey Man.
Hey, they all know that I run the show.
I'm a real gamer.
I'm a sexy baby.
No, I'm not.
You're telling lies again.
No way.
I said what I said.
But you're wrong.
No, I'm not.
Which one am I?
The real star.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, they show to me obviously.
I know.
They're talking about me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I told you they don't talk to their queen.
Oh, people talk to the real star.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're shouting at me.
Everything I feel.
I can't trust myself.
I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you think you're something?
What is this all becoming?
Just wait.
Hmm.
Try another time.
Well, yes, that's fine.
Everything's gonna be okay, though, in the end.
All right.
And there won't be anything to think about.
That's right.
Almost.
Tonight.
Just watch.
You're only doing this for the fun of it, though.
It's fine.
Do your best with everything you've got.
All right.
Although the rules are pretty strange, you've got a shot.
That's right.
So start.
We'll see.
Embracing everything.
You will not dance with us tonight.
It is not a time for words while I'm hanging for your very eyes.
And?
And a ballad for all my madness.
Very sad, very hard.
Hmm.
You stole a super, though.
Really?
It's funny.
Wish you'd probably stop.
Can you hear me singing?
Okay.
A ballad.
Stop.
To me.
Yes, everyone.
This is the song you want to sing.
Do you hear her?
Oh, what a voice.
Oh, look at her go.
I'm not ready to sing.
Oh, she really is.
I'm frightened.
I'm sorry.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
But she's our one.
Oh, we're so much for
that.
Oh, we're sure, always.
Always.
We're tied together half the time.
So really dance, dance.
Dance.
Together.
Get it.
Dance.
We want to say thanks for your hard work every day.
We're not going to complain
when we do.
And watch over us till the day we do.
You guys are like, who is it right now?
It's okay, you're doing great.
Everybody, don't be too crazy.
It's all live.
That's when you know.
Because it's not perfect.
Don't you worry, we're in Atlanta.
Watch this.
Oh, it's the Waffle House.
Yeah!
That's when you know it's the Waffle House.
We're not responsible for the Waffle House.
I fell out.
I'm disintegrated.
We hope you like our first song of the day.
Yeah, the very first.
Oh, and thank you, of course, to our wonderful opening act, Jun!
Wherever you are, up there in the 2D.
In the digital space.
In the 2D plane.
Yeah.
What else?
Oh gosh, I'm nervous.
I'm just tired.
I'm already tired.
I don't have...
Oh, I want to do something.
What?
What is it?
Whisps!
Yeah!
Alright, come out there.
You don't even have hands.
Come on, Dragoons!
Give me a cheer!
Hey,
Brooke, okay?
Alright, thank you all.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
We're going to love today's show.
The set list is amazing.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
This is not a regular VTuber concert, let's just say.
If you've gone to a lot of VTuber concerts, this one's different.
Alright, well, let's go get ready.
Who's going to be first?
Yeah, her or me.
Or both.
We're going to find out.
We'll see.
We'll see you guys soon.
See you guys soon!
夢を届ける日だよ 何もかもを忘れて くつろいでね 楽しんでね 少しだけを見て Yes, bring it on!
メイドリーミング メイドリーミング 家のふりで遊びましょう たっぷりの愛をこめて おきゅうじ笑顔でがんばっちゃう メイドリーミング メイドリーミング いつもここで待ってるよ 魔法のロウソクの火を 灯して愛を召し上がれ おいしくなれ 萌え萌えキュー
暗いこと楽しいこと みんなみんな持ってきて 幸せのおまじないで 全部笑顔に変えちゃおう 時計の針を止めて Zutto zutto issho da yo Ima shika dekinai koto kanaete ageru yo Tokete kirusou na ima wo Daiji na kakara mono mitai ni Shikkari dakishimete Baby, utone hanasanai de Fukurou ne omoi de Maydreamin' Maydreamin' Mahou no jikan de yokoso Ureshikute otome deshi Kokoro komete arikichau Maydreamin' Maydreamin' Sutekina egao mitai no Utatte hora
Nani nani?
Afuresou na
Owatte hoshii no
Tobimashou Taburi no ai wo komete Okyuuji egao de ganbacchau Maydreamin' Maydreamin' Itsumo koko de matteru yo Mahou no rousoku no hi wo Tomoshite ai wo meshiagare Egao ni nareru jumon Isshoni tomaemashou Oishii
Let's play mahjong together, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I'll find you and play mahjong Aiyo, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow My heart is beating fast You are smiling, you are smiling You love me a lot, my name is meow, meow, meow Every day I have your hug This is every minute and every second You are so important to me I want you to be more free than me You are my female friend Sometimes our little cat Has a bad temper and growls You are my brother You can melt my heart I want your little meow,
meow Let's play mahjong together, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I'll find you and play mahjong Aiyo, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow My heart is beating fast You are smiling, you are smiling You love me a lot, my name is meow, meow, meow Let's play mahjong together,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I want to smell your scent I want to smell your scent I want to carry your bag And sleep in your arms Every day I have your hug
Aiyo, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow Sometimes our little cat Has a bad temper and growls You are my brother You can melt my heart I want your little meow, meow
Let's play mahjong together, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I'll find you and play mahjong Aiyo, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow My heart is beating fast You are smiling, you are smiling You love me a lot, my name is meow, meow, meow Let's play mahjong together,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I want to smell your scent I want to carry your bag And sleep in your arms Every day I have your hug Let's play mahjong together, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I'll find you and play mahjong Aiyo, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow My heart is beating fast You are smiling,
you are smiling You love me a lot, my name is meow, meow, meow Let's play mahjong together, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow I want to smell your scent I want to carry your bag And sleep in your arms Every day I have your hug
I hope you guys have been super hyped right now in Atlanta for this special occasion.
I'm so happy to be here.
I found a new movie and everything.
I'm following you.
I assume that's how it goes.
Anyway, stay hyped.
We have a whole entire set list left.
So we'll see you for the next song, everybody!
Music in 1240.
Do me!
Go!
I'm puzzled.
I'm
confused.
I'm troubled.
I love you.
I love you, but...
What should I do?
I don't care if I'm a girl or a boy.
But, but, but...
Triangle, triangle love.
In an instant, in an instant, the balance breaks.
I'm following the rhythm of a normal love.
I'm a normal girl, but I'm a little over the top.
Triangle, triangle love.
Just kidding, just kidding.
If
I fall in love, I'll break down.
If I fall in love, I'll break down.
It's just one of those days, feel like a break trend.
First one to complain leaves with a blood stain.
Damn right, I'm a maniac.
You better watch your back, cause I'm fucking up your program.
And if you're stuck up, you just lucked up.
Next in line to get fucked up, your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker!
It's just one of those days.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit, let shit slip.
Or you'll be living with a fat lip.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit talking that shit.
So come and get it.
I feel like shit.
My suggestion is to keep your distance.
Cause right now I'm dangerous.
We've all felt like shit.
And been treated like shit.
All those motherfuckers that want to step up.
Hopping up like a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass raw.
And if my day keeps going this way.
I just might break something tonight.
Hopping up like a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass raw.
And if my day keeps going this way.
I just might break something tonight.
Hopping up like a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass raw.
I just might break your fucking face tonight.
Give me something to break.
He says bullshit.
Or you'll be living with a fat lip.
It's all about the
heat.
Talking like shit.
So come and get it.
This time...
I was trying to do barebone.
But my favorite idol group is Nicki Minaj and Kiss the Door.
And then of course...
Break stuff.
Yeah!
Um... uh... uh...
Oh wait, I forgot everything that I was going to say.
Um...
I'll make you guys
sing.
And show you all.
So it's very exciting.
Keep saying hi.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Well, my first time doing a full 3D show.
I miss all of you so much.
I didn't
hear any of that.
She hates us.
Did you hear all that nonsense?
You're not watching, right?
Where'd it go?
I don't know.
Okay, anyway.
We're still on the show!
Someday, we'll have a 3D show.
One day, it could be over.
Again and again.
All the memories of you and
I.
Lost in the wind.
Drink the last cup of coffee.
With a smile.
Drink
the last cup of coffee.
With a smile.
We're forced to unplay the same songs we've known since that day.
Imposter took our life away.
Now we're stuck here to decay.
Please let us get in.
Don't let us run away.
We're not like what you think we are.
We work for those songs.
We don't want no self-control.
And we're forced to take that role.
We've been alone.
A few mellow songs.
It drives me mad.
Join us, be a friend.
Or just keep on getting fed.
You're the only girl I like at Freddy's.
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna spend my nights at Freddy's?
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna spend my nights at Freddy's?
Like, surprise, we get to see you another night.
You should have looked for another job.
You should have said to this place goodbye.
It's like there's so much more.
Maybe you've been in this place before.
You remember a face like yours.
You seem acquainted with the stores.
Please let us get in.
Don't let us run away.
We're not like what you think we are.
We're poor little souls who have lost all control.
And we're forced here to take that role.
We've been all alone, stuck in our own show since 1987.
Join us, be a friend.
Or just keep on getting fed.
You're the only girl I like at Freddy's.
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna spend my nights at Freddy's?
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna stay?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
I'm just following my destiny.
How?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
What's the principle of nature?
The animals and the creature knows.
Cause survival of the fittest.
We're checking this out.
The animal that wins, gotta scratch and bite and claw and bite and punch.
And the animal that doesn't, well the animal that doesn't, well it's up someone else's...
L-L-L-L-Lunch.
Munch, munch, munch, munch, munch.
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
I'm just following my destiny.
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I possibly be?
There's a principle of business.
A principle of business.
It's what you know is the sound.
And there's a people of the melody.
People of the melody.
Because every living world's around.
So I'm figuring my company.
I'm figuring my factory.
I'm figuring my corporate side.
Figuring, figuring, figuring, figuring, figuring out where you take care of yours and me.
I'll take care of my, my, my, my, my.
I mean, let's shake that bottom line.
Let me hear you say, smart as gold.
Smart as gold.
Slippery slide.
Sloppily slide.
Complain all you want.
It's never ever gonna stop.
Come on.
How bad can I possibly be?
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing the economy.
Just look at me petting this puppy.
How bad can I be?
A portion of proof needs girls to share.
How bad can I possibly be?
Let's see.
How bad can I be?
All the customers are buying.
And the money's multiplying.
How bad can I be?
And the PR people are lying.
And the lawyers are denying.
How bad can I be?
Who cares if a few trees are dying.
This is all so gratifying.
How bad.
How bad can this possibly be?
I want to be the top.
I'm getting used to it.
This is different from peace.
I'm a number one star.
I'm being swayed.
There's nothing I can't lose.
I'm number one.
The
only thing that can keep us going is...
us, us.
Let's have fun.
Q.E.D.
My name is Sugar-san.
Everyone, jump out!
I'll come back to life.
I'll show it to you.
The truth is...
I'm going crazy.
I'll keep surprising the world.
My name is Sugar-san.
Everyone, jump out!
It's sweet and bitter.
My eyes are spinning.
Sugar-san.
Make some noise.
Let's have a party.
Let's go crazy all over the world.
On a night like this, I feel good.
No matter what happens, my collection goes on.
Let's go.
Let's go together.
Let's go crazy.
Q
.E.D.
Q.E.D.
Let me make it come true.
Let's go.
Let's sing.
Let's dance.
Let's have fun.
Let's have a party.
Let's go crazy all over the world.
On a night like
this, I feel good.
No matter what happens, my collection goes on.
Let's go.
Let's go together.
Don't get lost.
Put on your shoes.
Let's go out.
I miss you.
Don't worry.
I'm not alone.
I'm here for you.
Let's find a shiny treasure.
Let's go.
Even if you get lost, you don't have to worry.
I'll save you Shout out!
Let's whistle and walk proudly.
Fly high!
I hope we can reach that town.
Shout out!
Our future is full of dreams.
Fly more.
If you are here, everyone will smile again.
Even when I grow up, I won't forget you.
Our precious memories will last forever.
Ah, in my heart, there is a dream that will shine forever.
Try one.
Let me make it come true in your pocket.
Ah, let's sing a song.
Even if you get lost, you don't have to worry.
Fly more.
Let me make it overflow with dreams all over the world.
It's
starting to change, isn't
it?
The world is
a mystery.
I'm sure there's a place to enjoy.
The world is always there.
There is a dirty world.
Shock shock.
It's reflected in the window.
It's a dangerous light.
It's a star that disappears.
It's a star that passes by.
Sailors, let's go!
I'm going to dance.
Is that what we're going to do?
That Don Quijote.
One of us was lying.
Who is it?
When
you hear the song, you'll know who picked the song.
She agreed to it.
She said no.
That was true, and also our long-awaited guests.
Yay!
She can be my wife.
That good?
The best 30 seconds of my life.
I'm so humbled by your girls' ability to let me do it.
Cause honestly, I'd expect more from a girl who's better.
Cause she let me wear her chain and my turtleneck sweater.
So this was dedicated to the girls that let us fuck around on top of them.
Yeah!
We're a bar where the sugar told me.
We can't feel at all or let it get funky.
She can hook me on the watch.
Doesn't matter how tense.
But I cried the whole time.
She might have been a racist.
Doesn't matter how tense.
She put a bag on my head.
Still, girl, I just had sex.
Sex!
And the dreams came true.
The dreams came true.
She didn't have to dance in the last 30 minutes.
And it was the right thing to do with me.
I just had sex.
And it felt so good.
Guys, we hope you guys get lucky.
Woo!
Oh yeah!
I'm so proud of you.
So, here's to the beginning.
Always have to make your dreams come true.
Go with the flow.
Moonshine skip and jump step on the floor.
You are invited to the journey to the best of one.
Let's get started!
Take me, 나 시달러니.
내가 내가 내가, please guide my mind.
맘여라, 와라와.
맘마라, 봐, 하기를.
나 와있구나, 봐, 지금 봐, 두리번, 나쒀, 하이!
돈이 널 낳을까?
This is the second sentence.
And this is the third one.
Let's go!
Oh yeah!
Shake, shake, go on, there's never an end in sight.
It's alright, side by side, all our dreaming is fine.
Oh yeah!
Go on, open the ground and run, so hurry up.
Hito shi kiri yo tori, hitori kiri no toki no ku, haku wo umukatto mata pisu wa rama, yoso ijou ni omoidori ni, kanari mo, kitto, kono buki asu darou ne.
Dance, dance, I see the twinkles in your eyes.
All of the twinkling in your eyes.
The shining bright.
Shake, shake, go on, there's never an end in sight.
Mirai mo hanetai sachi, life no shinari wa bokura shinai madai.
Asa narai you ni mahou kagayou, hands up, let's go!
Tsukeridashita senbonzakuri, hana yoru wo aseru, yotsu wo umau, toki no kanari kara, owase kara, babamizu no machikara, kanarizu no magikara, uma no nai hodo ni, what's the fun in that?
Dance, dance, I see the twinkles in your eyes.
All of the twinkling in your eyes.
The shining bright.
Shake, shake, go
on, there's never an
end in sight.
Thank you guys for coming.
Thank you and have a great rest of your weekend!